a ban on non-essential travel between
france and the united kingdom has come
into effect the new restrictions
announced by france on thursday for just
a week to go till christmas set off a
last-minute rash
long lines in london as people queued
for hours for the eurostar train to
paris and in dover hundreds of cars were
backed up at the ferry hoping to beat
the midnight's deadline the french
government imposed the curbs to help
slow the spread of the omicron variant
the uk has seen a spike in corona virus
infections with more than 93 000 new
cases on friday
santa claus is coming to town
or maybe not of its paris he's going to
and his last stop was london
non-essential travel between france and
britain grinds to a halt on saturday as
strict new rules go into force
at paris's garth de nor christmas
holidaymakers were grabbing their last
chance to get to london on the eurostar
on friday i feel very lucky that i
managed to get
[Music]
out of france on the last day that it's
possible
but yeah i i
it is a bit worrying it's a bit scary
and who knows what's going to happen in
january when when everything
gets back to normal after the new year
so we'll see
um i think it's a bit late really
considering omnicom's already here as
well and it's obviously in britain so i
don't see why
considering people come from here from
france why we need the restrictions
we're fans of escape games so we thought
this is a grand adventure
we were looking for an escape game and
we found it exactly how to get out of
france and back from london
they'll make it out but re-entering
france from britain won't be quite as
jolly
across the channel there were long
queues at london saint pancras station
as people there sought to travel in the
opposite direction and get to france
while they could
from saturday even if the british can
convince french authorities that their
travel is essential
they'll be subject to self-isolation on
arrival
talking about a travel ban from the uk
to france we elia asked dw correspondent
charlotte charles and pale if this was
causing concern in the uk
well those that did have plans to go to
france clearly very very disappointed
we're hearing that they've been either
rushing to cancel or as i say rushing to
get across the border there have been
noises from tourism bodies as well
they've described this as a hammer blow
obviously they've been very very badly
affected by the pandemic over the last
year and a half so another
blow to them but
a lot of people in the uk i have to say
are really focused on the domestic
situation france has said that it's
imposed these restrictions because of
the rapid spread of omicron in the uk it
says it wants a chance to increase uh
its booster jabs there uh but the
situation in the uk really
is quite alarming at the moment the
number of cases has been rising for
three days running and i think it's it's
those case numbers that france is
looking at here let's now go to brussels
and speak to dw correspondent bernd
right bend countries across europe are
tightening restrictions and are now
reintroducing travel restrictions france
and austria have both reimposed them are
more countries likely to follow suit
we are already looking at a patchwork of
regulations
additional requirements and rules
portugal ireland
italy all of them have established
already additional testing requirements
france is now banning essential travel
from the uk
although for example you can enter a
train from the uk to belgium that's
still possible though there's also not
very logical all these restrictions
and austria is now taking the lead
because austria is only letting people
in who are boosted you can only get
there if you have three
shots if you are only vaccinated you
need an additional test and all other
people have to quarantine
and the netherlands are contemplating a
full lockdown again and also a travel
ban and germany also
is considering now some areas in europe
as high-risk areas so you cannot go back
without guaranteeing and
in the next days and weeks we will see
more
countries fall into this pattern so we
are back to the scheme we had last
christmas
and everybody wanted to avoid that but
the new omicron virus
is forcing governments to react
now clearly restrictions differ from
country to country could there be a
unified european approach
well bloodly speaking there is no
european approach there was a summit
just last thursday here where the
leaders
had the dire warnings on the table but
they ignored them
the ecdc the european center for disease
control the eu's own agency for this
purpose set you cannot stop omicron
anymore it's too late even
booster shots and vaccinations will not
stop this fifth or six waves in europe
you have to consider actually to to set
up makeshift hospitals to to to take
care of all these
hundreds of thousands and millions of
cases that are coming not as a wave but
as a tsunami and the leaders
well they did nothing they went home and
did then their own restrictions but no
coordinate effort they'd care about
their domestic situation the only thing
they agreed on they want to stop
travel restrictions for lorry drives for
example so that delivery chains at least
function over the borders
okay now regarding vaccinations you
mentioned earlier how well equipped is
europe for yet another wave
the eu commission here in brussels tells
us there is enough
vaccine there are enough shots for
everybody the commission is buying them
for all of europe and distributing them
there might be some shortages in the
first quarter of the year but this is
still can be still worked on with the
manufacturers
but the problem is that
the ecdc the control
agency says there's not enough time
anymore to prevent
the new wave by vaccinations or boosters
ben reget in brussels thank you
across the continent governments are
introducing restrictions such as
limiting opening times for restaurants
perhaps and venues vaccinating children
is another measure authorities are
taking to reduce their severity of
infections
a quick pinch
and it's all done
these kids in denmark are getting
vaccinated against covid19
i got the jab because of the new corona
variant and i don't want to be so sick
that i can't eat dinner
omicron is spreading at a fast speed in
denmark
infection rates are hitting daily record
highs
pushing more and more parents to get
their children jabbed
to slow the spread of the virus the
danish government has announced that
cinemas theatres and concert halls will
be closed
restaurant opening hours will also be
restricted
in neighboring germany the health
minister has raised the alarm
i'm assuming a massive fifth wave
we have to prepare ourselves for a
challenge that we have not yet faced in
this form
infection rates have been rising rapidly
across germany too
the easy spread of omicron would send
rates soaring even higher
as a result the german government has
now classified denmark and other
countries including france and norway as
high-risk areas
travelers will have to quarantine for 10
days upon arrival
unless they have been vaccinated or
recovered from a coronavirus infection
kai cooper schmitz is a journalist and
molecular biologist he joins us from
right here in berlin hello kai so are
travel bans and restrictions really
justified
well i think we have to look at these
two things separately and
there's a lot of uncertainty still about
what exactly the impact of omicron will
be what we do know is that it spreads
really really fast and that it is going
to lead to a lot of infections so that's
the reason that for instance in a
country like germany where we still have
a high number of uh you know unimmunized
people we need to be really careful and
that's the reason that restrictions are
being put in place and that seems to be
the right call at the moment
when it comes to travel restrictions it
is much more complicated we do know that
this virus is basically everywhere at
this point and
you know
all you can do with travel restrictions
really is slow down the spread of the
virus to your country a little bit and a
little bit spread within the country but
i think we're probably past that point
so i think that we should really be
concentrating on what we can do within
our own borders to to prepare for this
wave
okay so let me ask you a question that
is on many people's minds basically does
omicron affects the vaccinated and
unvaccinated in the same way
again you have to be really careful and
look at you know different scenarios
here
most of the data we have at the moment
is for people who've been vaccinated
either with astrazeneca or with pfizer
or modern vaccines and what we see there
is that the protection from symptomatic
infections so from a mild disease let's
say
is very very low if you've had two shots
of astrazeneca it's quite low if you've
had two shots of pfizer and if you've
got a booster it is much much higher
but the most important thing of course
at this point is the question what
happens with severe disease and the data
there for the moment i mean we're still
getting a clearer picture
but i'm quite hopeful that the
protection from severe disease if you're
vaccinated and boosted is really high
and so there is a huge difference
between people who've been vaccinated
and boosted and people who are
unvaccinated as we enter this this new
wave with this variant which we're still
trying to understand better
exactly uh quick one before you go so
what really needs to be done to prevent
new variants appearing
every couple of months how can we break
that cycle
well it's a complicated question because
the biggest thing we can do to reduce
variance emerging of course is to reduce
the number of infections worldwide as
long as this virus replicates in
hundreds of millions of people you're
always going to see a lot of mutations
and then you have natural selection
acting on this and
in the end you might get variants that
evade immunity or have other you know
have advantages when it comes to
transmissibility
so okay that's one thing that we can do
right now the hope of course is that
with new vaccines we might be able to
avoid infections and especially severe
disease better and in that case at some
point maybe we can treat this virus as a
lot of other viruses that we are
infected with every year that's the hope
okay journalist and molecular biologist
kai kofi smith thank you
you